[Musique]
les sénateurs
agissent budget 2024 l'air des déficits
extrêmes le Sénat se prépare à examiner
le projet de loi de finances pour
2024 ce texte prévoit et autorise
l'ensemble des ressources et des charges
de l'État pour un exercice budgétaire
donné Jean-François Husson rapporteur
général de la commission des finances
analyse les grands équilibres de ce
budget pour
2024 selon lui les prévisions du
gouvernement pour 2024 en matière de
croissance paraissent bien trop
optimiste surtout dans un contexte
d'incertitude
internationale ainsi d'après le
gouvernement la croissance atteindrait
1,4 % un chiffre bien au-dessus du
consensus des économistes qui retiennent
plutôt 0,8 %. dans ce calcul il
conviendrait en outre de prendre en
compte les conséquences à venir du
issement de la politique monétaire si la
croissance est plus faible que prévue le
déficit 2024 sera encore plus élevé que
les 4,4 % du PIB anticipé par le
gouvernement conséquence la France va
entrer dans l'aair des déficits extrêmes
d'ailleurs le déficit de l'État est déjà
passé de moins de 90 milliards d'euros
en moyenne avant 2020 à plus de 150
milliards d'euros depuis pourtant aucune
économie n'est proposée dans ce budget
au contraire le gouvernement propose
d'augmenter les dépenses de plus de 5
milliards d'euros en 2024 hors mesure de
crise désormais 45 % des dépenses de
l'État sont financées par le
déficit dans le même temps l'emploi
public augmente encore de 8000 effectifs
et aucune contrainte n'est exercée sur
les opérateurs de plus en plus hors de
contrôle dans leur gestion les Français
finiront donc par payer ce quoi qu'il en
coûte prévient le rapporteur général
dans un contexte où les taux d'intérêt
remonte l'accumulation de déficit
conduit logiquement à une augmentation
de la charge de la dette cette année
payer les intérêts de la dette coûtent
déjà autant que les budgets cumulés de
la police de la gendarmerie et de la
justice cela risque d'être deux fois
plus en
2027 pour en savoir plus consultez le
site Internet du
Sénat